féministe roland garros avec une
question qui pourra un jour arrêter
justine henin sur la terre battue des
internationaux de france nous les posons
la question dans un instant elle est
notre invité mais avant cela retour sur
sa victoire éclatante cet après-midi sur
la jeune et encore un peu de temps
ivanovic julien benetteau zidène berkous
la loi de la plus forte avec ce
quatrième titre à roland garros à
seulement 25 ans justine henin règne
plus que jamais sur le tennis mondial
même passer demain matin au réveil pour
être sûr que c'était pas qu'un rêve et
voilà l'aventuré continue pour moi ici à
roland-garros c'est tout simplement
exceptionnel quand j'étais une petite
fille je pensais jamais pouvoir réaliser
ça ici sur ce court central que j'aime
tant l'expérience des nains face à la
puissance presque juvénile d'ivanovic
le duel était plein de promesses il a
tourné court
je suis un peu déçu car j'étais trop
nerveuse je n'ai pas bien servi et elle
a très bien joué
c'est une super joueuse s'il aurait
fallu que je joue mon meilleur tennis
pour la 6 1 6 2 en un peu plus d'une
heure comme l'année dernière la belge a
survolé le tournoi sans perdre le
moindre set
il y à la supériorité dans le jeu mais
surtout cette extraordinaire force
mentale décuplé à roland garros
j'aime tant chez moi il est comme neuf
victoires si beaucoup de choses pour moi
hier mon caddie en tout cas l'année
prochaine et 86 et lumière une coupe de
champagne à la main et un autre rêve
dans la tête gagner wimbledon le seul
titre du grand chelem qui manque à
l'immense palmarès de ce sacré petit
bout de femme